los abogados de las casi 500 partes
civiles en este proceso comenzaron hoy
sus alegatos ellos coinciden primero en
manifestar su preocupación por la
tardanza que tuvo este proceso que se
volvió además muy técnico en algunas
ocasiones Y que muchas veces corrió
Incluso en el año 2019 el riesgo de ser
anulado están tratando ellos de poner
humanidad de poner sentimiento como
decía un juicio que debido al hecho de
que es un accidente aéreo se volvió a
veces muy técnico también demostraron su
preocupación o su enojo con el armador
europeo airbus porque la compañía en
todo momento ha inculpado a la
tripulación de este vuelo sin embargo
Ellos dicen que el bus conocía muy bien
el problema que tenían las sondas pitot
que son aquellas que fallaron y
provocaron este accidente sin embargo
Aunque había habido varios incidentes
una veintena lo hicieron nada por
cambiarlas y finalmente también los
abogados de la parte civil se quejaron
nuevamente en contra de
la compañía por no haber preparado
suficientemente a la tripulación para
hacer frente a una crisis como la que
tuvieron esa noche en la cabina los dos
copilotos y el comandante del avión las
dos compañías que en un primer momento
aparecían enfrentadas Cuando comenzó
este juicio finalmente parecen alinearse
en una misma posición se conocen ya hace
50 años por lo tanto no tienen interés
de enfrentarse dicen los especialistas
el bus insiste en que la culpa es de la
tripulación y el France aunque no ataca
directamente a quienes trabajaban para
la compañía los dos copilotos y el
comandante Sí dice que no entiende por
qué procedieron como lo hicieron y que
por lo tanto no puede manifestarse